Dubai for show like Dubai would be lit
can't take the weed there though but you
don't need it like Dubai so lit you're
not even thinking about the weed like
they having Lamborghini you've been in
Dubai of course not they go what no I've
not been to Dubai I'd like to go you
gotta go bro you got the passport don't
it yeah of course like the next time I
do a show and see hey for a rapper to
take before I rap [__] again for a
rapper to take care of the [__]
Dubai y'all [__] ain't took hell to
Dubai yet what the [__] y'all [__]
tripping okay how long you been doing
this [__] like 20 years damn yeah almost
15 15 16. that's long enough they got me
[__] up they got us [__] up they got
you [__] up what you mean Kevin do buy
it and you gotta password I ain't got my
passport no I got my passport I'm a girl
got your pass what's that we going to
Dubai y'all [__] tripping